j'adore marcher me balader sans réel but
est un luxe que je peux rarement
permettre mais un que de marché au lieu
de prendre le métro le vélo la voiture
j'adore ça il ya des petites choses que
j'adore quand je marchais le street art
et petites rues et les places et c'est
dur de faire une place qui marche bien
aujourd'hui on va se demander ensemble
comment entrer pour faire une place
publique qui marche bien certaines sont
très difficiles d'accès
d'autres sont faciles à s'approprier
mais tout est voulu quand on regarde la
place vendôme ou bien celle de la mairie
de paris on voit ce que c'était 60 ans
plus tôt on se rend compte qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de changement et ce changement
il se passe pas n'importe comment
cette vidéo elle fait en partenariat
avec la mairie de paris qui en train de
réaménager une place publique
dans une autre ville qui se trouve assez
loin que ce soit en terme de distance
d'histoire de culture et sept autres
villes
c'est bethléem donc en fait c'est un
projet de coopération entre la mairie de
paris et la mairie de bethléem avec le
soutien de l'agencé française de
développement est le mieux pour vous en
parler c'est peut-être d'aller sur place
bethléem ville sainte de cisjordanie
lieu de naissance de jésus de nazareth
se promener dans cette ville à quelque
chose de presque mystique
c'est une ville qui nous renvoie des
temps très anciens comme cette grotte où
marié aurait donné naissance à jésus
ou celle ci la 1000 go tôt où elle
l'aurait l'été on raconte que la pierre
est aussi blanche à cause de son la vie
mais j'ai une ville aussi qu'ils nous
renvoient à des temps actuels et futurs
comme ce mur et son street art
controversé qui sépare israël des
territoires palestiniens
[Musique]
c'est une ville de contrastes et ce
contraste est peut-être poussé à son
paroxysme sur sa place centrale
menchov square ventures skweres place de
la nativité la place principale de
bethléem est flanqué de la basilique
d'un côté et de la mosquée omar de
l'autre en tant que centre névralgique
et pan de repères on y trouve les
offices de tourisme
plusieurs banques et restos dommage
toutefois que le sert de parking aux
voitures
donc on est sur une des places les plus
importantes du monde la place de
l'église de la nativité et c'est un
parking j'avoue j'ai du mal à comprendre
comment on en arrive est en fait le
mieux c'est peut-être de demander un
local le dispositif porté par la mairie
est assez cool et c'est ça qui m'a
convaincu de vous en parler
l'idée c'est faire des groupes
d'étudiants en architecture avec des
étudiants français et des étudiants
palestiniens
encadrés par des professeurs et qui vont
apporter leur solution au problème de la
place de mende hier soir la première
étape c'est une étape de diagnostic
comprendre elle passe notamment par le
fait d'interviewer les usagers de la
place et lui c'est romain et les là pour
ça bref si romain et je suis là pour ça
il termine sa thèse en sociologie
urbaine il amené pas mal d'interviews là
c'est un monsieur qui s'occupe des bus
de touristes last un père franciscain là
c'est un monsieur qui s'occupait du club
de sport islamique
évidemment les étudiants ont mené aussi
plein d'interviews l'assesseur anna qui
s'est prêté au jeu
ils ont même mis un panneau dehors avec
un feutre pour que les habitants
puissent donner leur avis et voilà les
conclusions
bon on a interviewé des habitants de
bethléem et aussi des membres de la
société civile qu'on a trois types de
gens qui sont concernés par ce projet
premier essai des gens qui appuient
plutôt le projet et c'est ce qu'on
appelle les supporters qui sont pour un
changement mais qui n'utilisent pas
vraiment la place aujourd'hui
deuxième gros qu'on appelle ceux qui
sont attentistes qui sont pas forcément
pour un changement pour eux ce qui
compte c'est que l'espace public soit
propre et qu'il trouve une solution pour
leur voiture
c'est la classe moyenne basse et le
troisième gros c'est ce qu'ils sont des
pions ils sont dubitatifs vis à vis du
changement de la place car ils ont vu
plusieurs tentatives de changement non
fructueuse la seconde phase est une
phase de réflexion à partir de toutes
les informations qu'on va pouvoir
prendre de la place et des informations
il y en a un paquet par exemple les
lignes de la place avant de voir une
professeure faire secret
je n'avais pas vu que le motif sur la
place changé je veux aussi vous montrer
deux trois trucs que j'ai capté sur
cette place par exemple la ligne
derrière moi je pense que oui c'est pas
très clair en fait il faudrait vous
montre du dessus quoi ah voilà ok alors
déjà il ya des arbres que sur cette
partie ici tout le reste c'est sous le
soleil toute la journée et du coup
personne ne profite de cet espace
ensuite si les touristes et les pèlerins
qui vont à l'église de la nativité
eux ils font souvent ce trajet là enfin
les locaux font plutôt c'est trash à la
wii et les gens aiment se poser sur
démarche ici et sur des ventes puis ça
n'a rien à voir mais mon dieu que c'est
beau
[Musique]
donc voilà on va utiliser toutes ces
informations on doit aussi faire des
expériences et un moment j'ai surpris
des étudiants offert une faute de quoi
les filles à
[Musique]
we can change the way i used the price
et c'est intéressant de voir que ça a
marché laurie c'est vous qui avez
déplacé le banc non c'est eux qui l'ont
dépassée je crois donc vous êtes
contente bah oui a donc c'est parfait
comme ça marche alors et après c'est la
dernière phase celle de la proposition
ici les étudiants ont fait des
présentations orales triste est assez
intéressant il ya un groupe qui a
proposé de faire des arbres qui bouge
que les habitants peuvent déplacer à
leur guise
un groupe qui a prévu de faire des
changements de niveau sur la place pour
que les gens puissent s'asseoir un peu
partout d'autres ont décidé de mettre en
valeur différents chemins à travers la
place pour accompagner les usagers
un autre groupe a voulu transformer la
place en oasis et un dernier a voulu
créer de l'ombre sur toute la place à la
basse est en cours depuis le tout on
gagne vidéo mais finalement ce n'est pas
plus mal je pense parce qu'il ya du bon
à prendre dans chacune des idées même si
j'avoue que des arbres qui bouge c'est
un peu chelou
[Musique]
entouré de la mosquée omar d'un côté et
de l'église de la nativité de l'autre
mandje square et symbole de paix un
symbole de paix qui mérite mieux que
d'être en parking depuis quelques mois
heureusement la municipalité a décidé de
laisser les voitures rentrée que pendant
les événements et certaines prières ce
qui fait qu'on peut tomber sur des
scènes assez insolites comme cette
prière musulmane entre les voitures
devant une église
[Musique]
paris est une ville qui a énormément
travaillé son urbanisme
car il n'a pas eu le choix devant une
telle densité de population elle a dû
s'adapter
c'est problématique elle retrouve dans
d'autres villes où elles peuvent venir
apporter son expertise et son soutien
c'est exactement ce qu'elle fait à
bethléem il ya des projets comme
celui-ci et moi ça m'a aidé à me rendre
compte qu'une place publique qui marche
bien c'est pas évident et que mine de
rien on se débrouille pas mal
en tout cas j'ai hâte de voir le
résultat avec les aime et je crois que
pour ça j'ai pas d'autre choix que de
revenir love peace ciao